all right everybody it's been a while
but we have some phase four leaks to
talk about today and if these leaks end
up being true there are some pretty big
reveals here this leak talks about every
movie coming to phase four including the
x-men the Fantastic Four and blade so
we're gonna talk about and break down
these new big leaks in this video but
first huge announcement I have teamed up
with youtuber chaos and we're gonna give
away a Nintendo switch and the good news
is there are ten different ways that you
can enter this giveaway the biggest ones
obviously being following mine and
Chaos's new youtube channel multiverse
on YouTube Twitter Instagram and
Facebook
you also get points for following me on
Twitter as well and there are plenty of
other ways to subscribe just click the
link in the description it'll take you
to the giveaway page and of course at
500,000 subscribers I'm giving away an
Xbox one or a ps4 the winner gets to
choose so be sure to subscribe to my
channel so like I said this leak pretty
much talks about all phase 4 movies so
we're just going to start with the very
top of the leak so the very first thing
that it says is black widows father is
played by Ray Winstone Isabella Munir
plays a new KGB recruit mentored by
David harbors Red Guardian the main plot
of the Eternals is going to be black
night in Sarah's relationship Adam Scott
and brendan gleeson are cast as arrows
and xerus now we already know that the
Eternals is going to explore the
relationship between Black Knight and
sayers II but eros and Zira's have not
been casted yet or at least have not
been announced yet but Adam Scott and
Brendan Gleeson are actually pretty good
choices to cast as arrows and xerus now
Adam Scott would have to bulk up a
little bit to play arrows and the really
really cool thing about arrows is he is
the brother of Thanos that's right
arrows who typically goes by the name
Star Fox as Thanos's younger brother now
if this ends up being true which makes
sense because the Eternals movie should
explore Eris
that means Stannis will most likely be
in the movie as well so if you thought
we've seen the end of Thanos in the MCU
probably not
there aren't many ways for him to return
and this movie is going to be said way
before the events of the Infinity Saga
happened so I would expect to see a nose
in the Eternals then we have shang-chi
and the legend of the ten rings and the
leak about this is
pretty interesting apparently there's
going to be little connection to the MCU
besides the ten rings and also
apparently it's going to take place be
for Avengers endgame but after Avengers
infinity war that's a very interesting
time to have this movie take place but
at the same time there is a lot that
probably happened within those five
years so it would make sense that Marvel
would explore what happened during those
five years at some point in the MCU and
it looks like shang-chi is going to be
the movie to do that that means we could
possibly be seeing Hawkeye we know that
Hawkeye was traveling throughout the
world hunting down gangs and we know
that he was in Asia at one point in time
as well so perhaps he may cross paths
with shang-chi at some point in time
during this movie the next part says
that Doctor Strange into the multiverse
features the return of the ancient one
and Quicksilver it also says that David
Tennant is the studio's number one
choice for nightmare right now and that
makes sense he's a really good actor and
can play some pretty creepy roles now
the return of the ancient one isn't
really that big of a surprise but the
return of Quicksilver is now an Avengers
in game the Avengers discovered
time-travel so it would make sense that
they could go back in time and somehow
make it to where in the main timeline
certain people are revived such as
vision and Quicksilver now we already
know that vision is going to come back
obviously there's a one division series
coming to Disney Plus but I don't think
Quicksilver is going to return in the
same way because if you think about it
Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness is supposed to be the MCS first
horror movie and the Scarlet Witch is
supposed to play a pretty big part the
movie so the first thing that I think of
when I hear this is House of them House
of M in the comics is pretty horrific
and technically people do come back to
life but in a different reality and
that's probably something along the
lines of what we're going to see the
Scarlet Witch tried to bring her brother
back but she does it in a different
reality or an alternate reality that was
created during avengers endgame and I
think at some point in time it's going
to go terribly wrong and create sort of
a horror aspect to the movie the next
thing that the league says is that
spider-man 3 was planned to come out in
July 2021 before the Marvel Sony deal
fell apart this is something we all knew
Sony and Marvel have released a solo
spider-man film every two years so when
you
that the next one was supposed to be
2021 the next part is about Thor love
and thunder and says that it takes place
95% in space Peter Dinklage will return
as a tree Chris Pratt has a small
appearance as quill and Taika Waititi
wants Ryan Gosling and Finn wolf hard
for roles in the film it makes perfect
sense that for love and thunder would
take place 95% in space we've known for
a while that the future of the MCU is
going to be a cosmic future and we know
that Thor is going to be one of the main
characters to explore the cosmos and
they sort of already did that in Thor
Ragnarok when they were on the planets a
car now they're just going to take it
even further etry returning makes sense
he made Stormbreaker for Thor in
Avengers infinity war and we know that
Jane Foster is going to wield Mjolnir
and Thor love and thunder perhaps each
tree is going to be the one that makes
mule near for Jane and it also makes
perfect sense that quill would be in the
movie at the end of Avengers endgame
Thor went with the guardians of the
galaxy and Thor love and thunder takes
place before guardians of the galaxy
three so Thor love and thunder will most
likely start off with Thor being dropped
off somewhere by quill and also Chris
Pratt recently mentioned that you're
going to see him in the MCU before
guardians of the galaxy three so he
obviously was talking about Thor for
then this leek says that the Fantastic
Four is the February 2022 film now there
is a film for 2022 that has not been
named yet but it seems a little soon to
have the Fantastic Four be introduced
into the MCU however before the reveal
of phase 4 Kevin Feige once mentioned
that the Fantastic Four wouldn't most
likely be first because he did say that
the x-men were years away he did not say
that about the Fantastic Four and we
know that Peyton Reed the director of
ant-man and ant-man and the wasp already
has a script for the Fantastic Four he
pitched the script of Fox many many
years ago when they still own the rights
to the Fantastic Four and they weren't
interested at the time but we know that
he still has the script and we know that
he pitched it to Kevin Feige so perhaps
the Fantastic Four could be heading to
the MCU as early as 2022 the leak goes
on to say that black panther 2 is about
Namor taking over Wakanda Michael B
Jordan has a minor role as kill
longer in the film not too sure how
they're going to include kill monger in
black panther 2 if he does return to the
movie I think will most likely see him
in the ancestral plane this is where
T'Challa saw his father in black panther
if not that then definitely in a
flashback but Namor taking over Wakanda
Lokhande and Atlantis have a very long
history at going at it with one another
and fans have wanted Namor to be
introduced into the MCU for a very very
long time now so this would be the
perfect story for Black Panther - the
thing goes on to say that guardians of
the galaxy vol 3 is set to be released
in July 2022 Lucas till daiquiri
Montgomery and Zac Efron all met with
James Gunn about playing Adam warlock
and Mark Hamill is in the film as the
High Evolutionary now it's been rumored
for a very long time that Mark Hamill is
going to be in Guardians 3 as the High
Evolutionary but Lucas til daiquiri
Montgomery and Zac Efron meeting with
James Gunn to play Adam warlock could
just be fan casting there has been talk
about Zac Efron playing Adam warlock in
the past but that was just rumors but we
do know that the High Evolutionary is
going to be in guardians of the galaxy
vol 3 and thanks to previous leaks we've
learned that the High Evolutionary is
actually the creator of Rocket and James
Gunn has already stated that Guardians 3
is going to really explore Roccat story
arc the league vin says that blade and
Captain Marvel too are set for 2023 and
that the x-men reboot is a high priority
for Disney right now with Disney wanting
it to be released no later than 2023 now
Kevin Feige did say it would be a few
years until we see the x-men introduced
into the MCU
now we're at the end of 2019 now and if
they introduced the x-men at the end of
2023 that would be four years by
definition that is more than a few years
and you would imagine that the x-men are
a pretty big priority if not the biggest
priority for Disney right now since the
inception of the MCU Marvel has not been
able to use the x-men in the MCU they've
been dying to four years and now they
finally can since the Fox Disney deal
went through but they're not going to
Russia this isn't a film that we're
going to see in one to two years and you
don't even have to introduce them all at
the same time you can start by
introducing 1x
men or a few x-men in one movie at a
time so four years to make a movie where
you introduce an x-men into the MCU is
completely and totally doable and of
course Marvel and Disney know that
everybody is waiting for the x-men to
finally get introduced into the MCU so
you know that they're already on top of
it so that is it for this phase four
leak again like with all leaks take it
with a grain of salt a lot of things
that were said on here could definitely
happen and seem like they should happen
but of course it could always be
fanfiction but let me know what you
think would you like to see all of these
things play out in the MCU be sure to
let me know all of your thoughts in the
comments down below and again if you
would like a chance to win a Nintendo
switch be sure to click the link in the
description down below that'll take you
right to the giveaway site and again
there are ten different ways that you
can enter to win and of course at
500,000 subscribers I'm going to be
giving away an Xbox one or a ps4 the
winner gets to choose all you have to do
to enter that giveaway is be subscribed
to my channel like this video and
comment below with your favorite
superhero or villain don't forget to
subscribe to my personal channel culture
captains and as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof